foreign
good evening councilors ladies and
gentlemen and I welcome you to this
meeting of the council
before we formally start the meeting I
would normally ask my chaplain to say a
few words but he is not able to be with
us this evening having done a very good
job for the Civic Sunday service had
just gone by so at this point I'd ask
you to take your seats and I'm going to
read something in lieu of what he might
have read
I'm also going to read is something
which was part of that Civic Sunday and
it is something that was of course read
in the Palace of Westminster at the turn
of the Millennium from an Interfaith
Network
it's a very simple Act of commitment
and it's introduced by the words
in a world scarred by the evils of War
racism Injustice and poverty we offer
this joint Act of commitment as we look
to our shared future
and everybody there then committed
themselves in the following way
we commit ourselves as people of many
faiths to work together for the common
good
uniting to build a better Society
grounded in values and ideals we share
community
personal integrity
a sense of right and wrong
learning wisdom and love of Truth
compare sorry care and compassion
Justice and peace
respect for one another
for the Earth and for its creatures
we commit ourselves in a spirit of
friendship and cooperation to work
together alongside all who share our
values and ideals to help bring about a
better world now and for all generations
to come and I think those words probably
actually say what we really are about as
local councilors in this Authority this
great authority of Trafford thank you
ladies and gentlemen council members
we move on to apologies and I've
received apologies from absence from
councilors dagnorth Walsh newgrash
Freeman Andrew Weston and Taylor are
there any other apologies
councilor Maitland
councilor White
so that's eight sorry
so I've read Sophie Taylor yes you sent
a late message thank you very much uh
she's not able to be with us are there
any further apologies
in which case voting and broadcast
information we continue with a hybrid
system in the chamber this evening for
microphones and streaming the
microphones work by pressing the bar on
and off up to a maximum of three at one
time however we will still awaiting full
installation before we can use the
voting system and until then I will ask
for a show of hands should a vote be
necessary this evening
the meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
YouTube channel the whole of the meeting
will be recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items and this
activity promotes Democratic engagement
in accordance with Section 100a brackets
nine close brackets of the Local
Government Act
1972. Thank You So eventually to item
one the minutes the first item is
minutes and I move at the minutes of the
meeting held on the 15th of February
2023 be taken as read and signed as a
correct record is that seconded seconded
math thank you all in favor
all right thank you item two
announcement does the leader of the
council wish to make any announcements
this evening no announcements Murph
thank you leader do the chairs of the
scrutiny committees have anything to
announce on behalf of their committees
count Resurrection
information
[Music]
production of dependency
area
um
thank you councilor actor I know there
are quite a number of members of that
committee I believe it's next meeting is
on the 28th of the month now so
councilor wetton
thank you Mr Mayor just a very brief
verbal report as an update on the task
and finish group that has been looking
into access to GPS
uh it's a cross-party working of course
um but it was unfortunately delayed
somewhat by The Herder period
um which uh was just before Christmas
um the working included surveys of GPS
and have to be frank and say the the
um results of or the volume of responses
there was was disappointing
um we did also ask councilors for help
with resident surveys and
um we got a reasonable response there
but the content of the response that we
got was very good in in detail and gave
us a lot to consider
um the group has met several times and
recently met to discuss recommendations
so those are being
fine-tuned now and the plan is to
conclude with an interim report uh get
that signed off by the full health
scrutiny committee and we will then
publish the report before the end of
this Municipal year thank you thank you
thank you very much councilor wetton uh
councilor Denise Weston
um
so you got microphone sorry yes
uh
to get um at least an interim report
um before the end of the municipal year
thank you right we look forward to that
councilor Western thank you very much
um item three questions
as you can all see we have a very very
full agenda and to enable us to get
through all the business I appeal you
all to keep your comments concise and to
the point and to avoid requisition
item three is questions and members have
submitted 11 questions for this meeting
which have been listed on the council
website for members of the public to
view on the basis that all the responses
have now been circulated to all
councilors and will be published on the
west website in due course I will take
both the question and response as read
in each case and move on to the
supplementary in each case
all supplementary questions are to be
put and answered without discussion and
we will now take the questions in the
order in which they were received and
the first question was submitted by
councilor Myers
councilor Myers do you therefore have a
supplementary question uh yes thank you
Mr Miller thank you
can I thank the leader for his uh very
detailed response that was submitted
earlier the council tax in uh in
Trafford has increased by 26 since labor
took over
um just a leader have any idea when
they'd be keeping to their Manifesto
commitment
thank you councilor I'd also look
forward to your response thank you thank
you mayor um I think that that
supplementary is a rehash of the
original question if I'm honest so
um our definition of keeping council tax
low was uh was how it Compares with our
peers how it Compares with the greater
Manchester authorities how it Compares
with the Metropolitan Bush and as I did
say in my original response we are well
below the D band d uh average for each
of those comparator groups so I'm very
very proud I'm very grateful that
councilor miles brought this question to
the council because it reminds everyone
that despite the financial challenges
that all local authorities have been
facing over the past 13 years of
conservative austerity Trafford has
continued to maintain a low council tax
compared with our neighbors and it is
Our intention to carry that on and also
Mr Mayor just to remind people that in
the last year the last budget that the
conservative Administration put forward
they proposed a 4.99 council tax
increase so I really think glass houses
and stones come to mind when it comes to
this question thank you
thank you leader question two is a
question from councilor Denise Weston
I'm happy with the response I've
received and I feel happy with that so
there's no supplementary question in
this sense thank you very much question
three is the first of two questions from
councilor Morgan councilor Morgan please
with your first supplementary question
should you have one
um thank you very much Miss mayor um and
thank the executive member for an
incredibly lengthy response but his
response is a lot of reasons why the
council isn't doing more so to ask him
If he if he is returned to his place um
after mate what is his plans to to do
more to stop this blight on our
neighborhoods
sorry councilor ad said respond please
thank you thank you yeah and for your
supplementary question councilor Morgan
I think these particular things as
you've seen from the uh response and
it's quite comprehensive there is no
Simple Solutions to this and I think a
lot of things simply just move the
problem further down the road so I think
if there are particular problems we'd
have to look at each site in division
and see if there's a solution locally to
that thank you
thank you councilor ad said
um we moved to question four and just to
help members the second of councilor
Morgan's questions was on the topic of
20 mile an hour zones around schools Etc
councilor Morgan do you have a
supplementary question I do thank you
very much Mr bear and I thank again the
executive member for his reply and I do
appreciate the need to prioritize and to
Budget on these matters but this was a
Manifesto commitment from five years ago
and he's been responsible for this
policy area the entire period that the
labor Administration has been in office
I imagine it's something that families
across this Borough will still support
so to ask him why has it been dropped
thank you councilor Morgan councilor ad
said please respond thank you
thank you mayor and yourself
councilmography supplementary question
indeed these are themselves as you can
see there's actually is quite a few in
the Bubba already and we are looking at
particularly trying to do more however
in itself 20 zones himself of only part
solution it may or may not be aware I
did settle a special committee to look
at the whole aspect of safety around
schools around the borough I only did 20
zones is one of the things we did look
at when we first looked at 20 zones for
a couple of years two or three years ago
or so whenever it was exactly uh but one
of the things that come clearly to mind
at that point was particularly uh the
need for CCTV and obviously we didn't
have the power sound we've just been
applying for the powers now to give us
those camera you so we can actually
another way of actually enforcing these
however we don't have those Powers so we
had to consider the position did we go
ahead with some trials not using cameras
and indeed a number of authorities
around greater Manchester are doing this
and I and they're not easy to involve
because obviously each one is an
individual scheme but we have to rely
upon volunteers from local community and
I need those School themselves and
indeed we've had a number of discussions
with some of the schools around the
borough and all schools want to take up
this problem because the problem the
announcement I might allowed to get
volunteers to actually help with
Staffing the uh the barricade you want
to call it that where the world is
cordoned off so I think a decision was
taken that we wanted to proceed with
this and to look at these These are
trials they're from the future tfgm and
they are not uh they're not extensive as
online because London obviously uses the
cameras that we don't have yet when we
do have the powers to use cameras that
will be looked at further in the way to
do it but that's still a couple years
down the road so the question was do we
simply do nothing and wait for those
powers to come or do we try and get some
of these schemes in they are not easy
and say and rely upon volunteers and
support for more community and we're
discussing this further we're scrutiny
in a couple of weeks time so it's
something that I wanted to deliver more
I'd like to see a lot more of these but
they themselves will not solve all the
problems outside school so in some cases
twins on micro solution in another case
another type of scheme might be a
solution setup so there's lots of
solutions we want to do for schools and
this is one of them thank you thank you
very much councilor ad said so we moved
to question five which is from councilor
frass and it's going connection with
particular Road in timperley Council of
thrush do you have a supplementary
question following the answer that
you've been given uh yes Mr Mayor thank
you thank you so thank you for the
response indeed stretched apart Road
were resurfaced three or four years ago
but those stretches stop just before the
area in question so I think it's just
worth pointing out that in about a
month's time this very section of Road
will witness thousands of runners in the
Manchester Marathon the surface may very
well meet the bare minimum standards for
a vehicle although goodness knows how
but it certainly isn't safe for runners
I wonder if the executive would consider
accelerating that timetable taking into
account the marathon passing through in
about four weeks thank you thank you
councilor for us is councilor add said
again to respond thank you thank you
ma'am thank you councilor faster indeed
if you look at the uh the response to
the first part of the question is being
looked at further for patching work
however all these things have to be
programmed in so and we have to
obviously wait for things like school
closures to do these things in this
particular case have you seen from that
so in that sense I can't identify them
further to your point thank you thank
you councilor ad said a question six a
question from councilor Miss Blackburn
has received a response it concerns
autringham uh Town Hall an auction
Library do you have a supplementary
question given the answer you've already
received Council Miss Blackburn uh I do
Mr thank you um thank you for the
response um if old chingham library is
unable to hold evening uh Community
meetings will the council consider
another possible venue in Ultram Town
its Center itself thank you councilor
Blackburn councilor Patel to respond
please thank you
I'm you know it's a genuine offer to
explore that evening open plus system
allows that flexibility I think it's
something we need to just work through
in Practical terms around meetings I've
got a list of community buildings on
offer in Altrincham
um so you know that there's Alternatives
available within within the nearby area
so it's something we have looked into
thank you thank you councilor Patel
question seven the first of two from
councilor Holden concerns again uh grass
verges could you indicate whether you
have a supplementary question counselor
Holden
I do Mr Mayor right thank you thank you
I'd like to thank the executive member
for the comprehensive response I won't
pretend to understand the niceties of
the various levels of agreements mainly
beginning with s but
a very simple supplementary given that
comprehensive response how often
how often are these processes been
implemented over the last 12 months or
so
thank you councilor holding councilor ad
said to respond
thank you may I think it comes holding
for your supplementary in those terms
not quite sure what aspect you're
referring to there uh obviously I'm
aware obviously it just saying the
response quite clearly that obviously
these are inspected if it's a big
application they've inspected during the
implementation of the scheme so our
inspectors from planning and highways
will actually visit the site on
occasions I couldn't tell you how often
that is done I think certainly from
Highway suspected uh I'm a little bit
more knowledge on that but I haven't got
that information with me tonight we can
try and get that bit further but
certainly uh they're all inspected from
the completion of those Works obviously
it depends whether it's a huge site or a
small site but I certainly know that at
the end of the project they're always
inspected from both planning and from
highways in those terms there are
particular problems obviously as a world
counselor I had one problem in the
onward or a similar problem uh where a
large law has been driving over a
roundabout and a local speaker that's
unsuitable so obviously local residents
have supplied us with things like
falsely glass and the Damage photographs
of vehicles something get contact
telephone numbers and all Naturals cases
we can lays with and see if there's any
cost to be recovered but obviously each
case will be different and it's hard to
comment on one I'll leave this may
relate to a particular case you're
looking at so obviously I think uh
there's something we can help with
further at that police series after the
meeting we can see how we can try and
assist thank you thank you very much
councilor ad said so we move on to
question eight which is councilor
Holden's second question concerning
School places councilor holding you've
had an extensive response do you have a
supplementary question to this one
thank you again I'd like to thank the
executive member for Education sorry the
spokesperson
for the comprehensive and very
informative response including the
rather horrific numbers that's listed at
the bottom of the response where we have
162 children who will not be offered
places within their community and that's
really the basis of my supplementary
question
how does the council plan to enhance the
division of school capacity to allow
more of our young people to continue
their education within their communities
and not at a crucial time in their lives
be torn away from their friends family
and social group simply to fill in
partly empty schools thank you councilor
Holden and the response this time is in
the hands of councilor new
thank you for your supplementary
question Council Holden I'll respond
fully to you by email thank you
thank you and if you're going to do that
Council and you'll wonder is it possible
could you respond to all the members on
that basis because I think we'd all be
interested to know what the answers that
question is question nine is a question
from councilor Brophy and it is about
people with disabilities so councilor
Brophy of a response to this do you wish
to place a supplementary question I'm
getting a nod so yes off you go thank
you
so thank you to the executive member for
the detailed response I understand the
answer is to the first part my question
over one percent and the second part of
the answer is 13 cases so my
supplementary question is does Trafford
take into account all the additional
expenditure disabled people face in
maintaining their health and well-being
such as accessible transport adaptive
clothing or special requirements and
would the relevant executive member
outline the steps taken by Trafford
Council to ensure Financial fairness for
adults with disabilities and long-term
illness take into account
the current cost of living crisis
because I couldn't see that as part the
answer of what the additional measures
that take into account the cost of
living crisis yeah thank you very much
councilor Brophy the response on this
question is from councilor Karina Carter
thank you
um
uh thank you councilman thank you for
that
um as you can see from the answer
um quite a lot of care and sensitivity
is shown to the people who you call
Chase for debt I call reminded about
payments and you know so I I fully trust
the relevant staff that they will
um take into account people's individual
circumstances you're absolutely right
there's no cost of living has been
factored in I think we haven't received
any additional funding around cost of
living so it would be difficult to
factor into this but I think I trust our
staff in Trafford that they would handle
any outstanding payments with this
vulnerable client group with as much
sensitivity as possible if you'd like
any more further I'll have to go back to
the team but that's where I'm coming
from thank you councilor Carter for that
response we move to question 10
counselor new groceries question now
unfortunately Council is unable to
attend at late notice due to a family
situation however I understand that a
supplementary question which was to be
asked is in the hands of councilor frass
is that right
sorry Mr councilor Ennis I do apologize
thank you
I thank the executive member for the
response and clearly residents aren't
getting value for money from the Amy
contract that the conservatives have
signed us up to so what plans will be
brought forward to roll out more bins
across the borough and return to the
provision to original levels thank you
Mr Matt thank you councilor Ennis the
response once again is in the hands of
councilor ad said
thank you Ant-Man thank you councilor
Ennis for your supplementary I think if
you read through the detailed report
you'll see that this was started in the
early part of 18 and it was during that
period obviously before we took control
ourselves I can't see at that point in
time there a lot of the bins uh so as
opposition members we actually did
cooperate with the proposal because a
lot of the bins were knackered they were
simply
yes absolutely they were that medicine
was Rusty that there was uh some many of
them were actually opened tops that
meant as soon as you get a bit of wind
the litter would blow out so a proposal
from Amy at that time to actually invest
in these three old bins and did that
although it said initially with poster
from FIFA you'd take out theme and place
one that wasn't always the case it was
always in consultation with Ward members
and did a lot of these we relate to
Parks as well where Parks every time
they did a bit of fundraising money they
put in a bench or a little bin and quite
frankly there was there was massive over
provision in many of the parks in that
sense of it but again friends groups
were Consulting with them I was involved
in one of them in certainly the only
area as well in one case some young
world where what a street listening was
removed it was an open top one but it
actually also we it received a lot of
complaints from Neighbors nearby because
there was always a bag of rubber stuck
at the side of it from some nearby
residents so in that case when the
litter was gone not only did the letter
stop blowing out that the bags were
always up to the side were actually also
stopped as well so uh so it's actually
quite a complex issue so in that sense
of it we also got new Bins that were
enclosed so you have to put things in it
and they're designed to actually recycle
products as well so I don't think it's
going to say that uh there was a polls
up to actually just reduce the number of
bins it was about making it more uh put
into more decent bins on the streets as
well so we're in opposition at the time
but we did cooperate with that and each
of these sites was greeted by all Ward
councilors at that time if the world
councils weren't happy and I could say
it's an opposition member at the time
that then the naming would not proceed
with that but so we did reach agreement
in those points there so it was
disgusting so it wasn't a case of like
being imposed on Wards all Ward future
agreeing with that and the investment
itself was quite a huge one and a huge
cost of it and in that sense of it uh we
put a lot of provision out there and the
bins were designed to last for a long
time we also did a lot of cases in the
Parks you may have noticed particularly
whether you're simply bins that were
specifically for dog waste a lot of them
simply uh as you may know that they were
simply not done any more often because
the sheer weight of them that meant when
the officers tried to move the the bags
the bags split apart so you can imagine
this that was there and they deemed that
it was actually more appropriate to
actually use normal bin we'd actually
get more mixed rubbish in it so it
actually makes things like dog waste
more manageable so overall that is a
large investment and with the investment
in itself worked as in lesions like 15
years investment on it there so some
lessons uh if you have particularly a
one-way you really really need it try
and make a special case with what there
won't be any extra provision as well
simply because that that was that was a
really good proposal across the brother
although we're in opposition at the time
we did cooperate with it and we got a
lot of new Bins across there and it's
got a lot of the lifting that was going
on from bins that were simply not fit
for purpose thank you no thank you very
much councilor ad said so he moves the
last question question 11 which is with
councilman chalkin and concerns the
library in hayon proceeds from it so
councilor chalkin do you have a
supplementary question uh thank you
mayor thank you for the response Council
Patel there is no supplementary at this
time but I'm sure I'll be revisiting the
question once the Project's finished
right okay so no supplementary question
to question 11.
can move on to item four on our agenda
membership of Council on item forward to
revise the council the councilor Dr Carr
resigned as a member of council with
effect from the 20th of February 2023
this is for information can it be noted
thank you item five greater Manchester
minimum licensing standards for taxes
and I invite the executive member for
housing and neighborhoods counselor
right to move the recommendations for
minimum licensing standards for taxes
which have been recommended to council
by the executive councilor Wright yeah
thank you chair I'll be brief as I'm
hopeful members will recognize the
importance of extending the compliance
date for vehicle emissions and Age based
on the contents of the report and the
fact that any funding to assist with
this is not yet available move the
report chair thank you right the report
has been moved to have someone seconding
it yes yes Mr Hudson yeah I'd like to
Second it it definitely needs to be done
as evidenced by the number of frustrated
drivers we've had at the licensing
committee over the last six months who
are unable to access the financial
assistance
the GM clean air plan has unfortunately
been delayed so we hope this will be
sorted out
um before April 2025 and then fully
operational by 2026 so
um we therefore hope that everyone will
support this change thank you thank you
councilor German so council is wishing
to speak on this I've got councilor
Jerome to begin with
you do appreciate if you're sitting here
there are some people that are sort of
behind other people's heads as it were
and councilor but is one at the moment
on the layout
um so we've two Council of Jerome
councilor buck and the other speaker so
Council Jerome
thank you chair
um the tragedy of this report as
described in 3.6 is are we yet to open
the Clean taxi fund this means no money
has gone to taxi drivers to update to
newer less polluting vehicles in 2019 I
joined councilor Ann Duffield the then
chair of the licensing
to a passenger test on the EV black cabs
in Trafford Park the future looked
exciting and slightly Greener at that
point but since then due to no
government funding today and with the
bungling of Andy Burnham's gmca and
Trafford labor we still have no clean
air plan no clean air zones and still
find ourselves at Square One
residents are being left exposed to
polluted air on our roads like the a56
and all the harm to their house that
that this that this entails our budget
report tells tells us that NO2 and
particular pollution has risen over the
last year but yet we are told at 5.3 of
the report that 89 of chaffers haringey
carriage Fleet is not compliant due to
age or emission standards this is only
85 taxis why do we need to have a
cleaner plan to solve this why could
there not be more proactive in finding
funding and pressurizing government to
help this small cohort of drivers
the Administration has now been in power
for five years and we may not see
cleaner caps and taxis until April 2026
or even April 2027 if the contingency at
6.3 is deployed I'm sorry but we should
simply be doing better thank you thank
you councilor Jerome uh next speaker
councilor but thank you
okay mayor I just wanted to say on
behalf of our group that we're
supporting this uh
um item because obviously it's been
causing Fair bit of distress to the
drivers and the transition is difficult
but we need to support it thank you all
right thank you that is a report has
been moved and seconded
um can it be agreed
or would you like me to put it to the
vote no fine thank you well item six
traffic council's pay policy statement
for 2023-24 it is the annual pay policy
statement and I invite councilor Slater
the executive member for health and
well-being and equalities to introduce
the report which has been recommended to
council from the employment committee
councilor Slater thank you mayor
council's approach to chief officer pay
in particular and in accordance with the
requirements of section 38 of the
localism act of 20 2011.
it's an annual report to be approved at
Council employment committee recommended
approval at their meeting on the 20th of
February
once approved here it will be published
on the external website as we do each
year
the statement also incorporates the
council's gender pay Gap information as
the council is required to publish it on
an annual basis under the gender pay Gap
reporting requirements and this year we
have also added information about the
council moving to a real living wage
employer
we are now paying a minimum rate of 10
pound 90 to all substantive permanent
employees and casuals both within the
council and in our maintained schools
the application for accreditation was
submitted last month and we are awaiting
the outcome this is really positive news
and supports the ambition of lifting our
people out of poverty
I won't go through the whole report but
will draw attention to some of the
information in it this year
in May 2022 the government introduced
the statutory guidance on making and
making a disclosure of severance
payments by local authorities in England
and for noting this guidance has been
applied in Trafford and we have a policy
position that aligns to the government's
guidance and as such any exit payments
which needs to be approved by the chief
exec between there are over 20 000 and
under a hundred thousand as per current
Arrangements any payments exceed in a
hundred thousand pound come to council
for approval
in 2022-23 the council has appointed one
chief officer a deputy chief officer and
the corporate director of adults and
wellbeing
we also had one internal interim
appointment at chief officer level as a
director of communications who came in
to undertake a strategic review of our
communication function
I was gonna
um explain to people about the ratios
but it's quite in depth and so if people
have any questions around it you can
more than like happy to answer anything
around that so I'll just go on to say
that we are reporting the gender pay Gap
information and we will after tonight's
meeting if everybody agrees to this we
will be posting this onto our website so
I'm looking for the council to approve
this report thank you all right thank
you councilor Slater is that second dude
please
thank you leader do any members wish to
speak on this report councilor Jerome
again
anybody else before we turn to councilor
Jerome doesn't seem so off you go
councilor Jerome
it's time you might prefer as far as yes
Michael switched it on yeah
thank you we welcome the council space
settlement in what is difficult times
financially we know that the council has
exceptional staff that go often go above
and beyond as councilors we are often
provided with first class reports and
clear communication to help hold this
Council and its services into account
therefore we are pleased to see the
commitment to a very good pay ratio
green party policy would legislate a 10
to one pay ratio between the highest and
lowest paid workers in any company it's
good to see traffic doing better with a
pay ratio of nine to one and with no
bonuses for senior staff too the council
easily surpasses the heart and review
which recommends a ratio of 20 to 1
between highest and lowest so we welcome
that and uh just moving uh the word
document down sorry the green party has
backed the introduction of a 15
um per hour minimum wage for all workers
at its conference last year it's good to
see the council is aspiring and moving
towards a real living wage as a minimum
so this only stands at 10 pound 90. a
green Administration would be seeking
higher
there are of other courses of ways to
reward staff such as incentivizing
Government active travel schemes it was
however very disappointing to see this
Council provides 32 000 pounds for my
contingency budget to offer subsidized
car parking to staff this is the wrong
incentive I hope this won't be
continuing behind Beyond March 2023
thanks chair thank you councilor Giro so
I think that is the conclusion of people
who wishes to speak so
um
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please or would you
like me to put it to the vote can it be
agreed
thank you
item seven draft timetable of council
and committee meetings for
2023-24 and the council is requested to
agree the provisional calendar of
council and committee meetings 2023-24
pleased with the leader of the council
move this item councilor Ross thank you
mayor happy to move is that seconded
seconded thank you councilor Hines
um can I ask if the council is in
agreement or do any members wish to
speak this is a provisional calendar of
council meeting Council and committee
Mission anyone wish to speak probably
not thank you
um
oh
it doesn't actually say that you have to
approve this does it
we don't
it's missing from my script can we
approve that
thank you at this point in the meeting I
propose to vary the order of business to
enable the council to consider a request
for a waiver of the six-month attendance
rule as a matter of urgency a report was
issued to members as a supplementary
item of business last week
as members can see from the report
councilor dagnall has four medical
reasons and personal circumstances been
unable to attend any meetings in the
last six month period and these will
continue to prevent her from attending
meetings for the foreseeable a request
to extend can only be made by a council
prior to the expiry of the six months I
therefore move that councilor dagner be
granted an extension to the six-month
rule for a period of three months and I
invite the leader of the council to
Second the recommendation councilor Ross
please
thank you do any members at all wish to
speak to this report request
no the report's been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please thank you item 8
motions
I've now got a script that says this
evening five motions within listening
but I think we're down to four aren't we
yeah this evening motions have been
listed on the summons in the order in
which they were received however
as
with the two motions set out at 8A and
eight C are similar that's right sorry
the liberal Democrats are proposing an
amendment to 8A and as a consequence
have withdrawn their motion at 8C I
should have let my script better
shouldn't I as I mentioned earlier
please can we keep our speeches to the
point so that we can get through the
motions and give everyone who wants to
an opportunity to speak as usual it may
be necessary to limit the time for
speeches to enable us to get through the
business in time thank you motion 8A
preceding then with the first motion
regarding protecting our precious Green
Belt I have received notice that
councilor butt is to move this please
thank you councilor butt
thank you the Secretary of State for
leveling up housing and communities in
December made a statement in the House
of Commons in relation to an update on
the leveling up and regeneration bill
in this statement the Secretary of State
confirmed that whilst he will maintain a
method of calculating he believes that
the plan making process for housing has
to start with a number
and this number should be an advisory
starting point a guide from that is not
mandatory the Secretary of State further
added that it will be up to local
authorities working with their
communities to determine how many homes
can actually be built taking into
account what should be protected in each
area be that our precious Greenbelt or
national parks it will then it will be
down to local authorities to determine
how many homes can be built taken into
account many factors including
protecting our precious green belt
the Secretary of State further outlined
how those local authorities with local
plans at an advanced stage of
preparation who will not benefit from
these provisions
can take advantage of transitional
arrangements to produce plans that are
compliant with the new guidance
although this council is part of the
places for everyone's submission we have
no adopted local plan as such the
housing need calculation made within
places for everyone is now Obsolete and
not in line with national guidance
as such it is clear that trafford's
local plan be produced in line with the
new National guidance bearing in mind
the clarification outlined in the
secretary of state statement in the
House of Commons now this Council
resolves to withdrawal traffic Council
from the greater Manchester places for
everyone plan with immediate a priority
be develop a joint approach to
calculating housing needs through
Community call center consultations and
reinforced Brownfield first policy
and finally make a public commitment to
protect the Buddha's precious Green Belt
by removing the timpley wedge and
Carrington Moss sites from any future
local plan thank you Mr Mayor thank you
councilor but and I believe councilor
Duncan is to second the motion councilor
Duncan
thank you so you're reserving the right
are you hopefully maybe who knows
um we have received a notice of
amendment to this motion and I therefore
invite counselor Ennis to move this now
please councilor Ennis
thank you Mr Mayor there are several
ways in which the conservative motion
doesn't go far enough and once again
there seems to be some collective
Amnesia within the Tory group this time
they've forgotten about the origins of
Greenbelt development proposals in
Trafford because when they control the
council the Tories put simply wedge up
for development now they're in
opposition they want to follow the
example of liberal Democrat control
Stockport and call for Trafford to pull
out of places for everyone altogether
what a difference five years has made to
this conservative group and we'll hear
more from councilor Brophy about the
praise that some senior local Tories
have heaped onto places for everyone and
its predecessor schemes over the years
but still we welcome the last minute
conversion to Common Sense from the
conservatives
but the liberal Democrats have
consistently said no to timpley wedge
and Carrington Moss development
more than just saying no we've promised
we've proposed alternatives
we've brought forward this amendment to
set out what we would do differently to
address the housing crisis in Trafford
not that you'll find any mention of the
housing crisis in the conservative
motion
but since the late 1980s there has been
a house building shortfall of more than
000 homes a year that's 100 000 homes a
year every year for more than 30 years
that we haven't been building Mr Mayor
but we are certainly not going to solve
that problem with a top-down centralized
plan that builds five-bedroom luxury
housing on Greenbelt sites that have
been politically selected by the
labor-dominated combined Authority there
is something of a north-south divide
being created by this administration
because precious green spaces in the
north are afforded protection by the
council while sites in the South are not
nevertheless our Amendment recognizes
the work that has gone into granting
William Rowe its field of trust status
but no such protection has been afforded
to Greenbelt in timpley or in Carrington
and we must redress this unfairness
because what we really need is a truly
Brownfield first approach one that
maximizes the use of all Brownfield and
ex-industrial sites in Trafford and we
know because our own officers have told
us that if we chose to we could build 16
400 homes without touching a blade of
Greenbelt Land
but if we stick with Labor's combined
Authority plan who wins
not young people in Trafford who are
priced out of the area they grew up in
five bedroom luxury housing will do
nothing to give them a handle certainly
not the environment because we'd be
building over the only green one between
arborough and Manchester Airport and not
local communities either Mr Mayor
because they will be stuck with huge
over developments without any plan for
the resulting impact on schools services
and infrastructure if we go Labor's way
no one wins but the Developers
this Council can and must do better
that's why councilors should support the
amendment thank you Mr Man thank you
councilor Ennis and the second of that
amendment is I believe councilor Brophy
so in seconding the amendment let's make
this clear Trafford liberal Democrats
oppose developments on both timpley
wedge and Carrington Moss
it is worth remembering that the last
conservative leader of Trafford Council
enthusiastically promoted the greater
Manchester spatial framework the
predecessor to places for everyone
however the liberal Democrats welcome
the Tories turn around to support
Trafford withdrawing from places for
everyone
this is why we decided to withdraw our
similar motion from tonight's agenda and
amend the conservative motion
so going back when the liberal Democrats
held the balance of power in this
chamber it was understood that we would
vote against any proposals that would
remove Greenbelt protection from Simply
wedge
the then lib damp group myself and
councilor Ray balker propose adopting a
Brownfield first approach to the greater
Manchester spray spatial framework and
the retention of the green belt became a
priority in Trafford
it was understood then and reiterated
now that the liberal Democrat group will
not support house building on simply
wedge we are the only party that has
consistently opposed house building on
Greenport land at timpley wedge and
Carrington Moss for more than a decade
so what's missing from this Tory motion
is the aspiration to provide a fair
future for the Next Generation
the lib Dems believe that tackling the
housing crisis is as essential as
protecting the planet from climate
change
we believe that we can protect our Green
Belt our green spaces as well as provide
homes for Young People by building on
suitable Brownfield sites
so what we would like to see is the same
focused energy on preserving green
spaces in the south of our Borough as
we've already seen in the north of the
borough
many residents in the Autumn area feel
that the current labor Trafford
Administration does not represent them
the south of our borough is clearly
taken for granted by both Tories and
labor alike
developing timpley wedge would remove
the large open Green Space Between the
urban areas of timpley and hail Barnes
removing the green lung between these
communities and the airport
the current availability of greenspace
is in my area of timperley is one of the
lowest in Trafford
we know there are sufficient brownfields
faces in Trafford and a Brownfield first
approach would provide Trafford with the
homes it needs and it should be pursued
far more vigorously
I urge counselors to support this
liberal Democrat Amendment thank you
thank you councilor Brophy councilors
wishing to speak at this point
right right
until
um
right and in case I've missed any well I
have now uh councilors right could tell
whitham Coggins minis Holden Duncan and
Morgan
Winston
wins that sorry
it's Wednesday as a general sitting
there at the moment
Thomas right Thomas
so did was it counselor with him that
wanted to speak yes or no no perhaps not
so it's councilor Thomas Wright Patel
Thomas Cogan's minis Holden Duncan and
Morgan
and surely Proctor councilor Shirley
Proctor thank you
all right so we have 10.
right mindful of time I hope you're all
going to be fairly succinct and we'll
start the councilor right thank you and
we'll follow on with councilor Coggins
firstly I would just like to welcome the
Retro feel of this motion and Amendment
relating to places for everyone this
evening it's like it's 2010 all over
again the Tories and the liberal
Democrats in Coalition and United over a
common goal collaborating over a plan to
deny people the very Basics they rely on
and of course having no real plan to
tackle one of the greatest prices of our
time
I'll be very interested see what the
green party do when it comes to the vote
as well we could find ourselves with a
Rainbow Coalition of the regressives
this evening
just to make it absolutely clear the
labor group is voting against this
motion and the amendment in the
strongest possible terms why because
since we took control of this Council in
2018 we made a vow to increase the
supply of homes to make traffic Deborah
or if you want your children to buy or
rent a home in your community then you
can afford to do so we are unfortunately
still nowhere near achieving that goal
but neither will we ever going to be at
this stage
many of you will have been its executive
on Monday where I presented our
supported housing strategy a strategy
which will endeavor to assist in
providing accommodation to the most
vulnerable people in society
victims of domestic abuse sexual abuse
people with severe mental health issues
disabilities and carers both young and
old
you will also know the significant
increase in incidence of domestic abuse
mental health issues and children living
in temporary accommodation
this group does recognize much of this
Demand on supported and specialist
accommodation is twofold one because
this government has absolutely no
interest in providing social housing and
two because over the past 13 years each
and every service that provides and
supports vulnerable people has been
taken away funding is being cut in the
very Lifeline people rely on to get
through has disappeared and why because
of a Tory government's ideology that for
the first five years were rubber stamped
and voted through with liberal Democrat
votes
we have eight and a half thousand people
on our waiting list up from four and a
half thousand in 2020
the average age to buy your home
nationally is now 34 up from 27 in 2007
the average deposit required to buy a
three-bedroom 70 tax housing Timberly is
60 000 pounds
but neither the notorious nor the Deep
damage Cara jot about that if you if you
live with your parents
and your parents are lucky enough to
have some wealth that's the price you
pay to stay in your neighborhood and
that's fine according to live Dems and
the Tories if you have the wealth you
can stay if not we won't be increasing
Supply around here you can go elsewhere
and of course what nimby's and I'm
afraid that's what you are
don't don't understand is how to it's
how to solve the housing crisis
Brownfield land empty homes high density
you're living in a fancy land I'm afraid
what do you think the riddings wrote
Reading Road estate was built on in
simply the estate that I live on it
wasn't Brownfield land it was open land
Farmland land that we were considered to
be green belts or Greenfield today
the same applies to Southwest area and
many other areas of Trafford the homes
that a significant number of the people
in this chamber leaving
will almost certainly built on what we
would what we would consider green belt
or Greenfield today
it's also worth noting however what
impact withdrawing from places where
everyone would mean
as it's a collaborative plan being part
of it means there is there is a
reduction of 4 000 homes from our Target
equating to one square Swan square
kilometer of green belt if we withdraw
from places for everyone
we will almost certainly be required to
release more green belts that is
currently planned for
this has also been proven
and I would like to draw your attention
to a recent planning appeal that was
successfully won by a developer of the
world of pet sites in timperley
a plan that will deliver 45 affordable
homes not the five-bedroom luxury homes
that have been described by others this
evening
a plan that because places forever and
places for everyone hasn't even yet been
adopted an officer from these Council
and members
voted against it and was recommended for
refusal at planning committee rightfully
this site is within the temporary wedge
allocation
places for everyone is not yet adopted
the land is still within the green bells
and the land is not currently allocated
for housing yet despite this the
planning inspector recognizing the
housing crisis in Trafford and the lack
of affordable homes decided to allow the
appeal this is the reality hide behind
Brownfield land in high density
developments all you like but a
real-life planning inspection even in
current Greenbelt Land is being approved
for development
I also find it nauseous that in both the
Tory and the liberal Democrat group we
have a proportion of people who
undoubtedly benefited from free
world-class University education the
largest and most sustained economic boom
of all time and relative to today homes
that were around five times cheaper to
buy
and now having benefited from that
themselves they are more than willing to
deny the generations after that
something as simple as a Home of Their
Own in their own community
what however makes me even more nauseous
is the fact that people of my generation
or below in those parties tonight are
going to vote in favor of a motion that
denies their own generation and
generations to come an opportunity to
afford to live in a home in their own
neighborhood
I'll end with a quote
selfishness is the greatest curse of the
human race who said that the liberal
Prime Minister William Gladstone thank
you chair thank you councilor Wright and
as I've said the next speaker it will be
councilor Coggins to be followed by
councilor Holden
can you turn your microphone on thank
you
okay I think I've got one
uh can I confirm you want to discuss the
amendment and the motion all at once is
that right oh look at the moment we're
discussing the amendment if that's all
right I'll speak to the amendment now
and I'll come back later on the motion
thank you right
um with uh with the choice permission
obviously
um we agree with a lot of what the lib
Dem and conservative groups are
attempting to do tonight but we also
disagree with what a lot of um what both
groups are attempting to do tonight
um I will talk just about the bits that
are only in the lib Dem Amendment at the
moment
um in particular it focuses on
um it says a plan that works for
Trafford borough is best developed in
Trafford by this Council and in
consultation with the people we
represent I think that tells part of the
story but to be honest it seems like
quite a brexit assumption
um and that we need to actually work
together with our neighbors in cooperate
and the problem that we see with places
for everyone and gmsf before it was not
the crossborough cooperation in fact
that is something that we very much
agree with and think that we should
continue with in this as much as
possible the problem was the
prioritization of mindless economic
growth over protecting our climate and
so although we
agree as I say that there are many many
things wrong with places for everything
we feel that the lib Dem amendment is
focusing on the wrong element and so we
won't be voting for that tonight and
I'll speak again if that's all right on
the other issues thank you we have the
opportunity right thank you very much
councilor Coggins councilor Holden next
and after which will be councilor Patel
thank you Samir
I was part of the conservative group
that first considered the allocation
excuse me my voice is dying
better no it's not that's better
this was in 2010 to 2012. those of you
who've been in this chamber for any
length of time will remember my
spectacular Fall From Grace
from the executive in 2012 followed by
10 years of nothing
that was because I expressed my concern
about Carrington
from day one
and look where it got me so be careful
so I won't take any blame for it at all
I don't think it's entirely such a bad
idea but let's not make any mistakes
this is a labor decision
Carrington Moss to be destroyed
they're built on
as a decision that labor don't have to
make but have chosen to make in order to
protect a disused golf course in flixton
and it's not the housing that's the
problem although Heaven only knows where
the children are going to go to the
schools or where they're going to find
GP surgeries it's the ill-considered
road
that one single decision The Duel
Carriage away with a VIP Lane for the
members for Buckles at Martin's to get
quickly to their to their award and the
cycle Lanes will just divide Carrington
Moss into two easily digestible slots
which like
the world of water
will be swallowed up into any sort of
housing
so all I would say I can say what I like
here tonight
because it'll have no effect the only
people who have any influence on this
situation are the labor group who are
dis making the decision to destroy the
Moss all on their own because they don't
have to anymore they could say no but
they won't thank you Mr Mayor thank you
councilor Holden as I said councilor
Patel to speak next and then councilor
Duncan thank you I too am reminded of
that cozy moment in the Rose Garden in
2010 we didn't place any trust in the
plans of the toys and libderms then and
we shouldn't do now lib Dem scare
tactics on Housing Development deployed
in the Chatham and Amish and by-election
sent the Tory back benches into Free
Fall the Tories were once the party of
home ownership and now in panic trying
to finish off already Dyer house
building efforts in this country I can
see how those who oppose house building
in Trafford think that the Secretary of
State's remarks in the Commons represent
a gotcha moment but you couldn't be more
wrong sadly for those agree with the
amendment and the main motion it's not
an accurate reflection of the written
ministerial statement or critically the
subsequent proposed amendments to the
National planning policy framework the
radical promises of the Secretary of
State made to calm down the blue shires
were not actually reflected in the
proposed amendments to planning rules
these changes do not propose the removal
of nationally set housing targets do not
propose any immediate changes to the
current standard methodic methodology
for calculating local housing need
wording of the use of previously
developed land remains unchanged so no
Brownfield first on steroids policy
critically these amendments do not
provide appropriate transitional
arrangements to authorities at an
advanced stage of plan preparation to
take advantage of them and this is where
we're at with places for everyone the
places for everyone public examination
is currently ongoing and progressing
well both our Carrington and timperley
wedge allocations have had their hearing
days and we look forward to the
inspectors recommendations in the next
few months please have a look at these
sessions available on YouTube they
provide an informative look into the
actual reality of plan making policy on
the ground I know no counselors who
oppose places for everyone took an
opportunity to have their say at these
sessions the nine GM authorities take
the position that the proposed draft
changes to the mppf do not provide a
sound legal basis upon which to make the
decision to withdraw we remain fully
committed to the process
I would like to take the opportunity to
challenge a couple of specific points
being made that we have no local plan
this is not correct we have a robust set
of local policies and we'll be picking
up work on our new local plan which is
already at its first draft at the end of
this year that plans to develop
temporary wedge will remove the last
green open space between timpley and
hail Barnes is not accurate a
significant green gap of 328 hectares
will remain between timpley and hail
Barnes which includes for their creation
of a new publicly accessible rural Park
the ask of places for everyone amounts
to allocating
6.6.74 of trafford's green belt for
planned and coordinated development
planned investment into transport and
infrastructure and the collection of
coordination of developer contributions
the remaining
93.26 will be protected from speculative
and inappropriate development it's
really sad to see the opposition parties
have lost their Collective Minds over
places for everyone you have created a
political football on which to spearhead
outrage and political gain you represent
the absolute epitome of what is wrong
with our planning and house building
Ambitions in this country in contrast
this Administration stands with eight
other GM authorities to speak for those
whose voices I never heard in this
debate that's those locked out of the
housing market and it's not just young
people anymore but a whole generation of
people in their 20s 30s 40s who
currently have little hope very little
hope of owning their own home in
Trafford those who support this motion
do not speak for everyone far from
Progressive you represent established
vested interest I would urge the lib
Dems to speak with your colleagues in
Stockport and reflect on whether they
consider their Green Belt now safe from
development they are deluded if they
think they are
this is the absolute position this
absolute position that there is a
straight trade-off between Environmental
Protection and infrastructure is a false
Choice I'm immensely proud of the work
done within places for everyone it
represents exactly the Strategic
approach we should be taking towards
housing infrastructure Environmental
Protections and employment I could go on
and on about the benefits of places for
everyone and hope I get a chance to do
so in Council in the future I urge
everyone to vote against this inaccurate
and hyperbolic Amendment and motion
thank you thank you councilor Patel
right at this at this point we have six
more speakers councilor Blackburn above
copper you'd have seven just about to
remember what I'm going to say
um the councilor Ms Blackburn has come
into the phrase well now gather
councilor Williams we are still on the
amendment we are already now beginning
to run behind so that speakers from now
on having heard quite a lot of speak
both in favor and against the amendment
are opposed to suggest that we have an
absolute absolute maximum of one and a
half minutes per speaker for now and
this is on the amendment thank you so
councilor Duncan
new system seems to be about as good as
the old one doesn't it really
as I meant yes right we we okay okay
thank you
councilor Duncan thank you okay thank
you this labor and Council have had the
potential to build on Currington moss in
their entry for five years
so this labor-run Council about not one
year not two years
not three years not four but five years
to pull the plug
so it would be interesting to see how
much it cost the taxpayer of the five
years knowing this could have been
scrapped five years ago
residents in Man Award and Beyond
do not want current to Moss to be built
on so does labor real listen to local
residents concerns
wood Trafford labor please withdraw the
build on Carrington mosque thank you
thank you councilor Duncan we moved to
councilor Thomas And Then followed by
that councilor Minis
thank you mayor I'm unable to support
the motion put forward by the
conservative World conservative and the
amendment but also by the liberal
Democrats can I for many reasons
including ranky postgraphy can I remind
the council that the a short number year
ago the conservative groups German F
included
and the p4e plan that we have put
forward includes a 40 reduction in
Greenbelt that is being uptaken
flicks and William Rowe golf course
which wasn't Greenbelt and it wasn't
used as a tool to safeguing to Moss was
voted for unanimously by the
conservative group at the time
the lemon open regeneration plan that
Michael Gove has brought in
as was finished its uh consultation on
the 2nd of March and until then housing
will be used as a standard measure until
at least 2024 so Council but statement
was wrong
um Stockport the liberal Democrats since
they pulled out of the gmf gmsf their
their Target in the gym I said for 793
homes per year on the current standard
Matters by the conservative government
it is now
1186 homes per year uh 17 700 in fact
over a 15-year plan period and based on
the Strategic housing land availability
assessment which is the latest available
data
51.79 hectares of employment use
buildings and equivalent to 21 football
pictures are what Stockport will lose I
cannot cannot support this ridiculous
motion thank you councilor Thomas to
council a minute to be followed by
councilor Morgan
thank you Mr bear
places for everyone or the former gmsf
in Trafford is ridiculous in terms of
planning so I'm just thinking about when
from my experience on the planning
committee and from my understanding
building on Greenbelt should not be done
unless there's a huge public benefit and
exceptional circumstances
the additional housing on simply wedge
is not going to be affordable we all
know that for future Generations as it's
in Hell bonds which is the wealthiest
ward in Greater Manchester
it's the green lung that protects us
simply folk and Hell her folk and it's
um residents of Temple in Hell from the
pollution at the airport Manchester
Airport and which is a home to rare
Wildlife that will suffer from
development in summary the benefit of
the Hill building expensive houses is
not big enough to outweigh the harm
caused then there's the infrastructure
there's also the highways and the ice
assessment should be done in realistic
terms considering all roads including
Park Road and timpley which is busy
enough quite frankly as it is to develop
the Carrington Moss site involves
digging up a peat bog its natural carbon
sink and it's responsible it is
irresponsible for us to approve to cause
irreversible harm to Future Generations
by releasing the carbon captured and
destroying the biodiversity already
present I cannot in all conscience ever
support such a poorly uh thought-out
idea whether it's been thought out very
well at all the solution to pull out of
it and develop our own local plan is
really the right thing to be doing
rather than just deciding to carry on
thank you thank you councilor minis
councilor Morgan to be followed by
councilor Shirley Proctor uh thank you
Mr can I speak on the main motion after
the chance Council okay I would speak
now if I were you fair enough
sorry on that one
um thank you Mr Mayor it's
um Council of writing Council Patel so
negatively of Tory lib Dem coalitions
but to be honest with you I've always
thought of them very positively but
maybe that's reflection of my marriage
um uh this is a really simple motion
indeed it's the main platform of what I
stood on in 2019 so it's an area book
irony it book ends my time in this
Council
um I've represented a huge number of
communities with some hail Barnes
timpley Hale well green Davenport green
and in that time what is underlined is
the opposition to these plans across
those communities to Labor's plans the
green belt was designed to stop urban
sprawl and that is what it is doing it
is there to ensure that residents have
access to Green spaces and that is what
it is doing
so what do we need to do Mr Mayor we
need to stop going for the easy
solutions every developer will want to
build on greenfields it's the
comfortable choice for them to do what
we need to do is a proper local plan in
the borough and to build on Brownfield
sites
the world has transformed since 2020 the
potential on our Brownfield which was
always there has been unlocked by the
changes caused by the pandemic all it
takes Mr Mary's ambition to use them
thank you
thank you councilor Morgan so we moved
to councilor Shirley Proctor to be
followed by councilor Miss Blackburn
thank you
Mr Morgan
when I first went to
stand as a council a second time
actually I spoke to and supported the
friends of Flix and Greenbelt
at the time the Tories wanted to build
on flicks and green Felts
you are adamant you were building on it
I won
very very easily because I said Over My
Dead Body
was Flix and Greenbelt going to be built
on and I still say that Over My Dead
Body flicks and green belt will not be
built on
also just for the people who are
commenting on about the north-south
Divide Carrington is actually in the
north of the borough it's about a mile
and a half from my house and I live in
flixton
that's all I wanted to say thank you
thank you counselor Proctor
um moved to council and Miss Blackburn
and then to councilor Williams
uh thank you Mr Mayer and I'd like to
make a statement if that's okay and the
conservative group several years ago
were persuaded by professionals to
support the previous greater Manchester
spatial framework on the basis of
Brownfield first
Green Belt would be considered only when
every Brownfield site was utilized and
that would be many years in the future
this was retracted later and it was
stated that it was never suggested and I
stand by this statement as a truthful
person thank you thank you councilor
Miss Blackburn councilor Williams
and thank you chair
um aim to be brief I I solely want to
express my belief that the very minimum
we should expect in discussions such as
the one we're holding tonight is that of
honesty frankly I consider it pretty
disingenuous of the liberal Democrats to
attend Council this evening and it was
an assert repeatedly that they favor a
Brownfield first approach to development
whilst at the same time proposing to
oppose oppose infrastructure measures
which would allow housing development in
Carrington the vast majority of which
will be located on a Brownfield site
which is the largest single Brownfield
site for development pretty much in
Greater Manchester the liberal Democrats
are trying to have their cake and eat it
this evening and I think we deserve
better thank you chair
thank you Council Williams before I just
move to my next words does anybody else
wish to speak at this point
councilor Coggins you've spoken once can
I propose that we put the amendment to
the vote I think it's something
by procedure and ask whether councilor
but who's the right to reply to this
amendment first of all and we'll go in
that direction
but as the proposal of the original
motion you have a right now to reply to
the debate on the amendment
if you don't wish to say anything that's
entirely up to you
right thank you right in that case I
will now put the amendment to the vote
point of order Mr math does the Mover of
the amendment
no
um
not according to my script and I trust
our officers implicitly in this respect
so putting the amendment to the vote all
those who are in favor of the amendment
okay all those who are against the
amendment
there's quite a lot of people right so
the amendment is lost
we are left with the original motion and
we are just about approaching the time
on my timetable when we should have
finished this debate on this motion and
since we have therefore had substantial
discussion I believe on both sides of
this motion I propose without any
further debate to move to put the vote
on the substantive motion I can see
Hands
um
check could I just make a quick point
that some of us prepared to speak to the
amendment and then prepared to speak to
them the substantive motion and we were
doing that in previous meetings but now
we seem to have changed the rules so
what what should we be preparing for
when we come to Council meetings well I
I it's it's my decision really that the
fact I believe that we have had some
very very substantial discussion on both
sides of the argument whether we're
talking about the motion or whether
we're talking about the amendment I can
see where people's opinion is I don't
really think that we need to spend any
more time on it if we do spend much more
time on it we will run out of time I do
not wish to see a motion move from this
meeting into the meeting in July which
would be the next one and therefore I
wish to put the original substantive
motion to the vote now all those in
favor
this is the original motion the original
conservative motion as unamended
can we have a point to order
if um if I may I I did ask at the very
start if you wanted me to speak to the
amendment or not we have heard a lot
from all the other parties you said
we've heard both sides of the argument
our argument is that this isn't about
two sides it's more complex than that
and so just soon we did actually
specifically clarify that we would like
to speak to both right I'm advised
councilor Coggins that this is not
actually a point of order so there
effectively I will have to overrule you
and I will put this original substantive
motion to the vote as unamended it's the
original conservative motion unamended
sorry councilman
all those in favor of that motion
unamended
thank you all those against that motion
is defeated
[Music]
sorry you can't
you can't abstain if you wish I'm sorry
I didn't ask for that those wishing to
abstain are the four green councils
that's fine thank you very much
motion 8B now is a motion about making
votes count with proportional
representation and is moved by councilor
Welton councilor Welton please thanks
chair members the year is 2000 instead
of giving us the Millennium Dome Tony
Blair uses his massive labor majority to
reform the electoral system a gift for
the ages labor are by far the largest
party after the 2001 election but need
to form a coalition with the liberal
Democrats lacking lib Dem reform support
for putting British troops in Iraq Tony
Blair steers George W bush away from
invading saving countless lives and the
destabilization of the Middle East at
the 2010 election a coalition still
forms between the conservatives and the
liberal Democrats but under PR the
liberal Dem the lib Dems win 157 seats
rather than 57. they resist pressure to
raise tuition fees and stop the bedroom
tax
the Coalition government's signature
achievement is enacting the social care
reforms proposed by the dill not
Commission
the actual 2015 election was among the
least proportional in British history
but under PR Nigel farage's ukip wins 83
seats but with the conservatives utterly
split over EU membership their attempts
to form a coalition with ukip fail and
there is no referendum or brexit instead
a Rainbow Coalition forms rather than
David Cameron cutting the green crap
Caroline Lucas as Minister for the
environment oversees the launch of the
green New Deal that sees massive
investment in insulation and renewable
energy decisions that Shield the UK from
the energy price shocks of the 2022
Russian invasion of Ukraine but of
course the Russian invasion of Ukraine
doesn't actually happen under PR without
brexit destabilizing the EU Putin is
deterred from further aggression his
regime already weakened by the strict
money laundering rules brought in by the
UK's Rainbow Coalition government at a
local level budgets don't get cut by so
much and the conservative lib Dem
Coalition running Trafford Council
don't sign up with Amy for 23 years in a
desperate effort to fill its blood
budgetary black hole
let's fast forward to 2023 after nearly
25 years of proportional representation
the UK now resembles a modern European
social democracy its politics is more
consensual more caring and less prone to
capture by powerful groups on the
extremes of the major parties elections
are no longer narrowly fought over the
support of a few thousand voters in key
swing seats housing becomes more
affordable with the government no longer
dependent on ever increasing house
prices to shore up political support
this frees up Capital to invest in other
areas of the economy UK productivity
Rises as a result with the economy set
to match German rates of productivity by
2025. members alas we cannot rewrite our
political history but we can change our
future this is not some stale
constitutional issue of little relevance
to ordinary voters fairness in our
electoral system is at the heart of
social justice without Fair votes we are
destined to repeat the mistakes of the
past
there's a huge Progressive Majority in
this chamber the greens and lib Dems
have long advocated for PR and last year
Labor's conference voted in favor of
electoral reform it's time for us to
join the many councils across the
country who are calling for a fair
voting system together we can build
pressure for Change and ensure that when
this diabolical blue Kip Tory government
finally Falls its disastrous rule
supported by a minority of Voters in
2019 is never repeated please support
this motion thank you thank you
councilor Wilton I believe the motion is
to be seconded by councilor Coggins
thank you mayor um yeah it's worth
taking a look at last local elections
here in Trafford which um gave us a very
interesting results I have brought a
visual aid I have a few copies passed
around but not very manly
um but I think you can get the vibe from
from looking at this the top one is the
votes cast by party and Trafford and
last year's local elections in May when
about one third of you were elected and
the uh chart below is the actual
representation We've Ended up with in
this chamber
um I think the first thing you see if
you look at that is that labor got less
than half of the votes casts that's not
even taking into account low turnouts
and so on less than half the votes cast
and but you can see in terms of the
number of people in this chamber we have
a gaping Pac-Man
um of of Labor taking 65 of the seats
only 45 of the votes and the other
parties have been squeezed in a
similarly distorted way and so while 13
point five percent Trafford residents
voted green you can see up here and that
should give eight or nine green
counselors which of course we do not
have in fact we have the smallest number
of cancers at four less than the lib
Dems five who got a lower turnout a
lower vote than us for ten percent
um an unusual feature of this election
is that the Tories are actually
underrepresented in this chamber and so
the Tories got 30 percent of the popular
vote but only 20 of the seats so um our
friends on the far side should actually
be encroaching much further into this
part of the room if the people in
Trafford were properly represented by
our system
and this is actually an atypical result
uh looking back historically and over
the long term the Tories the dup and the
SNP have been the big undeserved
beneficiaries of our warped system
um and the one big change we would see
uh apart from the money uh changes
Michael described earlier uh if we had a
PR system is more Progressive
governments more generally labor-led
governments fewer conservative
governments
um but this isn't about what the
outcomes are this is about
representation of people and PR is a
feminist issue
um our Parliament and our council
chambers are deeply unrepresentative we
see women people of color people with
disabilities and Manning other groups uh
profoundly unrepresentative but
unrepresented and we know that broken
first pass the post system actually
increases this discriminating against
all of those underrepresented groups in
fact any of us who are concerned about
underrepresented groups need to think
about that fact that's literally what it
means it means that we have a system
that is discrimination against people
and in fact you can see this very
clearly in places like Scotland where
you have both first to pass the post for
Westminster and uh proportional system
for the Scottish Parliament the very
same voters
um elect a more diverse Parliament to
the Scottish Parliament than they do to
Westminster because the system
discriminates
um people aren't happy to continue
playing this game of voting for the
least worst option and we really need to
push for a fairer way of voting that
gives more power to people to choose MPS
and counselors that really represent
their views and all of us are here to
represent the views of our residents and
the fact is the system is stopping us
from doing that well so I'd really call
on all of you to work within your
parties to change the system to give our
residents a better representation thank
you thank you councilor Coggins
um I have received a notice of an
amendment to this motion and are
therefore now invite councilor frat to
move this now please councilor for us
thank you Mr Mayor I've seen the look on
many a face over the years as the
resident liberal Democrat Saddles up
their hobby horse to talk about
proportional representation so I shant
rehash some of the familiar arguments
put so well by our colleagues over the
corridor and the green party but a quick
counter through some quirks might be
interesting or useful of course our
haphazard system designed by no one
evolving over centuries does produce
some rather curious results at the last
election the SMP with just 1.2 million
votes got 48 seats my own party achieved
more than three times as many votes yet
3.7 million votes somehow gives us 11
seats at the other end of the scale the
green party's 8 000 votes left them with
one MP but the dup's two hundred
thousand eight hundred thousand votes
left them with one MP but the dups 200
000 votes rewarded them with eight so
why do we have a system where the more
votes you get the fewer seats you have
in Parliament it is any wonder that
people lose faith in our political
systems when they don't work this brings
me to the point of the lib Dems
Amendment the labor party has voted
twice now in two successive years to
make voting reform a key part of their
next Manifesto the first attempt was
thwarted by the unions in 2021 the
second attempt seems to have been
Shrugged off by secure starmer in 2022
he did appear in the press the next day
to say it's not a priority however the
mayor of Greater Manchester has defied
this labor leadership and has come out
in favor of modernizing our democracy as
he puts it with the influence of our
altering mp on the Wayne since
announcing his retirement the voice of
Andy Burnham is undeniably more
influential and the position he holds is
arguably more suited to calling for
reform and the Scottish and the Welsh
have more modern voting systems that
keep that precious constituency link
that is so Central to British democracy
but it also ensures that their
parliaments and their councils are
proportional and yet greater Manchester
with a population comparable to that of
Wales and with its own Devolution
settlement has no such rights to
determine their electoral future
therefore the lib Dems feel that this
was a useful addition to the green
party's motion thank you thank you very
much councilor frass councilor
Ennis is to Second this amendment
secondly Mr Mayor reserve the right to
speak okay right the amem has now been
moved and seconded do any members wish
to speak to the amendment
it's like
what else
right
can you keep your hands up please sorry
I've only got at the moment oh
I have the leader councilor Ross
councilor Wright Council of Welton
councilor Oxford
any others at this point
so we
want to go first
councilor Ross the leader first of all
thank you
thank you mer
um I have to say to start off with I am
a supporter of voter reform I'm a long
supporter of voter reform I think people
are in different parties are aware of
that I regret the fact that the liberal
Democrats in 2010 didn't take up the
then prime minister Gordon Brown's offer
of voter reform without a referendum and
went off with the conservative and had a
botched deal in 2011.
I have to say though it isn't the thing
that keeps me awake at night what keeps
me awake of night is making sure our
children and young people get the best
start in life it's making sure that we
provide housing and regeneration in our
Borough it's making sure that we get the
basics right and work with our
contractor to make sure that we we
deliver the services that people expect
from us and it's making sure that we
provide support to people when they're
at most in need now later on Mr Mary in
in this agenda we will be bringing you
what are the real priorities for this
Borough in the form of the care care
experience people as a protected
characteristic and a reflection on the
poverty truth commission I have to say
as someone who is a long-standing
supporter of voter reform the thing you
need to do is carry a room with your
arguments and I have never
or I should say seldom never heard some
self-indulgent rubbish coming from both
the greens and the liberal Democrats
you're talking inwards you're talking
about yourself you're talking about your
electoral chances you're not talking
about the people out there that we're
elected to represent so I have to say I
found that the strangest set of speeches
that I've heard in a very long time
incredibly inward looking and is not our
priority as a labor Council so yes I
know there are colleagues in my party
like me who support voter reform but
frankly we're not going to be supporting
that nonsense tonight thank you thank
you councilor Ross leader um
whether it goes your counselor Welton
we'll be regarding this as a friendly
motion and that's all I was going to say
until that extraordinary Outburst from
the council leader really
this should be what keeps him awake at
night and if he was actually listening
so what I was saying a lot of the
problems that we were discussing in the
in the debate earlier regarding housing
regarding the problems in the housing
market would actually likely not exist
or at least to the extent that they do
today if we had a fair voting system in
this country and we hadn't had the last
13 years of Tory dominated rule which
undoubtedly we wouldn't have done under
a fair voting system because this is a
progressive country there's very little
that separates our proportion of votes
from Germany from the Scandinavian
countries the one thing that happens
every single election is that our
electoral system distorts the result and
if you distort the results of us of an
election you'd distort the resulting
government and if you distort the
resulting government you distort the
policies you change the electoral system
you change a lot of the problems in this
country and the things that you care so
much about so I'm extraordinary I'm
strictly disappointed to hear such a
flippant response
to what is a deeply serious subject and
to be honest to be honest it really is a
poor indication of what we're going to
get under a future labor government if
this in here presented with an
opportunity just to support PR
is all you can come up with really I'm
I'm absolutely gobsmacked thank you
thank you councilor Welton councilor
right
thank you chair I'll be brief um I'm not
sure using the brexit party going in
gaining seats in Parliament as you do in
the motion as a reason to support
proportional representation is a great
way of gathering labor support in the
room
um I think maybe you should sort out the
pr of your motion before you put forward
a motion on PR thanks chair good Lord
right thank you councilor right
councilor Oxford
I'm speaking against this motion because
whilst I agree that our electoral system
desperately needs reform to create a
fair system in which every vote counts
simply voting today to agree to a system
of PR is meaningless without given the
issue the time and importance that it
merits and without considering all the
options and
repercussions in an informed way there's
no doubt that there's public appetite
for reform as already mentioned the
labor party voted to support a PR motion
at its conference last year
um and Andrew Burnham is also a pleasure
to support for PR it's clear that the
cooperation and consensus that will be
needed in a coalition government would
be an effective way forward for tackling
complex issues such as a climate crisis
however I think it's simplistic to
assume that a PR system would
automatically win back the trust of the
electorate instead we did all our
politicians to start acting from a
position of Integrity honesty fairness
and humility
I suggest instead that we that perhaps
we could have a cross-party discussion
with information briefings to evaluate
the merits the different systems on
offer and then if we wanted to if we
were in agreement because there may be
create some kind of statement of support
or motion if appropriate in that way we
could demonstrate the benefits of
working collegially and cooperatively as
it would be as would be required in a
future PR system as a first step towards
winning back that electric electoral
trust thank you
thank you councilor Oxford I got
councilor Mercer wishes to speak before
we move
clarify that I'd like to speak to the
emotion but not the amendment
when quite have time for that possibly
um right now at this point counselor
Wilton has a right of reply to the
amendment or the as the he's waving his
hand he's waving that right so I've now
put the amendment to
didn't reserve the right Mr Mayor okay
that is the amendment uh yes yeah all
right thank you Mr Mayor um the botched
deal in 2011 at councilor Ross has
referred to was because labor broke
their Manifesto promise and renewed on
their pledge to campaign for the
alternative it's important to clarify
that AV is not PR and Council Ross knows
that
now this is about our resident voice
it's about making votes matter councilor
Welton has done an excellent job in
spelling out why this makes a difference
in people's lives tangible difference
Council Wright says we want the PR but
only parties he agrees with should be
represented fairly that's not democracy
we can do better than that
um I urge colleagues to support this
amendment and the motion thank you
councilor Ennis an apologies for not
allowing you to uh do your seconding
back to councilor Wilton anything to add
at this point no thank you thank you
councilor welcome so at this point we
know I will now put the amendment to the
vote all those in favor of the amendment
okay all those against
all those abstaining
so the amendment is lost so we can go on
to
speeches on the original motion prior to
being amended who wishes to speak
Mercer blackbird
Jerome
Proctor yeah
I've got councilors Mersa Blackburn
Jerome Proctor anyone else at this point
in which case we'll start with councilor
Mirza thank you and go all in that order
Blackburn Jerome Proctor
so chair I question the motive for the
motion as indeed the leader of the
council has done so and whose interests
this motion is in
I wonder whether it is indeed in the
interests of the party
proposing the motion and indeed the
amendment
and we have seen within the motion
itself a snapshot of a particular
statistic eight hundred thousand votes
three hundred thousand votes and the
equivalent of one seats that they uh
acquire
what really matters is what's in our
national interest or British interest
and in the interests of our voters
I thank councilor Walton for the
theatrical history lesson but he missed
out from that history lesson a very
important episode in our very recent
past and that was a 2011 National
referendum on electoral reform in that
election two-thirds in fact more than
two-thirds 68 percent of those who voted
voted against the proportional
representation system that was being
offered in the form of alternative vote
and voted in favor of our present first
pass suppose system
why did the British public do this well
they did it for three reasons I say
firstly Clarity our current system of
election is a simple system a short
ballot paper and a cross to be put on
it's not a complex electoral system
Clarity the second reason is uh
Simplicity we know who represents us we
have a named counselor in a ward or a
name Member of Parliament we have a
geographical area covered by a
representative rather than an arbitrary
National or Regional percentage being
adopted within a particular locality and
finally stability
the current system of election leads to
a stable government whether it's local
or national
rather than
the reference the references to the
three prime ministers in the recent past
is a improper reference because we still
have a conservative government a stable
conservative government
we do with a very strong majority as we
all know
but that's not the point here the point
is it we do not have a frequency of
Coalition governments hung parliaments
hung councils let alone hung
Representatives
so these themes are very important the
themes of clarity stability and
simplicity and it is those themes that
we should bear in mind when considering
this motion our first pass the post
system if we're to be described in one
word would be fair the individual with
the most votes wins I oppose on behalf
of the conservative group this motion
thank you councilor Mercer so a
counselor as I said in the order in
which I took the names councilor Miss
Blackburn
uh thank you Mr Mayor proportional
representation Tosh thank you
thank you councilor Miss Blackburn
um
that that will be particularly easy to
minute I guess
councilor Jerome next thank you thanks
Joe it's pretty hard to follow that but
uh
but I'm surprised by councilor Ross's um
Outburst quite strange really because
one of the troubles that we do have in
this council is connecting with our
residents we've spoken about the budget
in an executive and full Council before
and I believe that this budget only 18
people
um bothered to take part in the
consultation and that's because we don't
connect with people out in the borough
enough
and PR would help to revitalize our
democracy and help us to engage with the
wider Borough
um
councilor Ross's answer was that um
counselors should go out and speak to
their residents more but in his own
terms labor there are no labor
councilors for a third of the borough
and very few activists too so it means
you're not speaking directly to the
proportion of the borough PR would help
um parties to reach out to The Wider
Borough to gain votes across all Wards
and get their message across so I think
PR would Revitalize our system and make
sure people are more connected to what
we're doing at the council
um but also I'm surprised by councilor
axford's response I don't know we've
been criticized in the past for not
backing our statements up with an
amendment an amendment would have been a
good thing here to have taken that
debate further amongst councilors in a
Collegiate way as you say thank you
chair thank you councilor Jerome now our
Gala councilor Thomas also wants to
speak and we're beginning to run out of
time on this one as well so can we just
cancel a proctor first then councilor
Thomas can you limit yourself to two
minutes please
thank you
keep me awake at night
sync between Heating and eating
private sector rents being so
unaffordable for people in Trafford
families in Trafford families
sleeping in their car
because they haven't got anywhere else
to live
the government increasing benefit
sanctions even though their own research
shows it doesn't work
police officers committing sexual
violence
that's what keeps me awake at night not
here
thank you councilor Proctor councilor
Thomas thank you chair just just on the
pr in the local Council I was elected in
flixon last year I'm quite well known
infliction I've lived there all my life
and I'm quite aware of the very local
issues that go on around flixton if I
was elected in the pr and perhaps
assigned the ward I don't know simply
I haven't got a clue what's going on in
timpley
PR within the council takes away the
local knowledge of the councilor
it doesn't allow everywhere I was voted
and I won unfortunate representation in
flixton Ward I wasn't elected as
anything else thank you thank you
councilor Thomas
um councilor welcome you have the right
of reply as the proposal of the original
motion thank you it's a quite
extraordinary what we've heard this
evening I think we need PR uh clearly
because we obviously need to shake up
this chamber because the standard of
some of the responses has been should I
say Tosh uh thank you very much and also
slightly insulting as well and I will
I'll repeat the point I made in response
to councilor Ross earlier that
this voting reform is exactly how we get
the change on the issues that you know
that that really really matter
do you really want a future that
prioritizes the interests of a very very
narrow band of Voters in swing seats
because that is what parties are
prioritizing at the moment that is why
policies for years for Generations have
prioritized property the property owning
classes you know that is the inevitable
conclusion of our current political
system
when we could have a future where
governments succeed by agreeing policies
that are in that National interest
led by parties that can demonstrate the
support of the majority of the
population and finally I mean look at
your fellow parties in Wales in Scotland
particularly talking to the labor group
here yeah
they're not far away but you think that
any of them would change back to a first
past the post system now
and there is a link in their systems
with constituencies as well so this is a
completely ridiculous argument it's a
completely false argument
and to come to finally to come to Cal
Council Mirza
um
the alternative vote system isn't a
proportional system 2011 wasn't it
wasn't a referendum about proportional
representation it's not a proportional
system so I suggest that there is
some seriously weak arguments in here
tonight and also a real fundamental lack
of knowledge of the issue and I really
really think people need to go away and
and have a good read and a good think
thank you thank you councilor Welton so
we come to a vote on the substantive
motion all those in favor of the
original substantive motion all those in
favor
four all those against
extensions
none so the motion is fails is not
carried motion 8 D as indicated earlier
motion HC has been withdrawn so we turn
to the next motion on making care
experienced as a protected
characteristic and this is to be moved
by councilor Shirley Proctor please
thank you
motion to cancel
why does it matter to me so much
well we all need to belong in a loving
stable family but for some of our
children that isn't possible in their
birth family
and for many reasons they come into the
care of the local Authority
I grew up in a family who fostered from
me being four we had foster children
and I saw firsthand the damage that
actually coming into care causes being
ripped away from your family no matter
what was going in that family causes
damage
so children are having to deal with that
damage Plus
the consequences of the reasons why
they're brought into care in the first
place
I with the other counselor Proctor and
the support from the Council of Carters
councilors Carter
fostered 13 children over 13 years
in Trafford
they were children of different ages
different backgrounds different issues
and varied reasons for coming into the
care of the local Authority for some
their birth families couldn't cope for
others others they were being actively
harmed by their birth families
our first foster children are now 31 and
we're still very involved in their lives
and have witnessed the long-term effects
of being in care has caused them through
no fault for their own
placement changes can pile up the issues
faced by children in care making it even
harder for that child causing them to
feel rejection hurt and a lack of value
the lived experience of being in care
can massively impact your
self-perception your self-worth your
confidence and your ability to trust
others
some carers experienced young adults
don't want people to know they've been
in care
others don't mind we have one of our
foster children who will call me to
others Auntie friend sometimes mum
another one doesn't it's I'm a friend of
their family because they for them it's
private
I grew up being treated differently due
to my disability
and this has continued since it became
more disabled in my 40s but I'm
protected in law
and I can take action to stop
discrimination
I'm also much more confident than I was
as a child
having other protected characteristics
triggers discrimination as well
just as having been in care can we heard
it from those amazing young people who
spoke to us this evening
we heard first hand
some of the issues they they deal with
on a daily basis
by recognizing care experience as a
protected characteristic we confirm
that it's worthy of protection
and we can challenge such discrimination
in the same way people with other
protected characteristics can challenge
that discrimination I ask you to support
this motion thank you
thank you councilor Shirley Proctor
I believe that councilor Heinz is to
second the motion
I would request that I remain seated
please absolutely no problem whatsoever
at the moment thank you and so I guess
to some degree it's quite reassuring
that we haven't continued our evening of
consensus that we had in the last
meeting and there's something a
comforting about that but I am hoping
that we will return to
um some consensus for the sake of this
motion I'd like to thank councilor
Proctor for bringing the motion which I
am incredibly honored to Second
um because it is a really important
motion and it's something that we did
consider bringing a couple of months ago
um as some other authorities were
beginning to adopt a similar position
and but we thought it was important to
engage with our young people first so
that we could make sure that it was as
meaningful as possible for for them
really
um and it was and anybody who who was
here I think will agree that it was a
very powerful to hear them speak to us
earlier this evening in this chamber
about their experiences and about how
they can play a vital role in developing
the policies and strategies that impact
them and I have the great privilege in
my lead member role to meet lots of our
care experienced young people
and to work with some of them on the
corporate parenting board and I'm always
incredibly impressed by their talent
their skill their honesty and their
determination and tonight was really no
exception they completely bowled me away
and and like always they really made me
think
um and I think about my own Teenage
children and my son who's 18 and at
universities living away from home for
the first time and my 16 year old
daughter who's doing a gcses and I think
about all the things that we talk
through together about their lives their
Futures where they might live what they
might want to do and all the paths that
they can take and to help them get there
and I do think about
um how they're just starting out in life
and if if something happened to me
um and and my family if we weren't there
for them how I'd really hope that this
that society would also want the best
for them
um and the young people told us this
evening that they're seeking stability
in their lives understanding and
patience from us and a voice in
determining their own Futures and it
doesn't sound like too much to ask for
to me so what I hope we can do with this
motion is yes I I absolutely think that
we must protect care experienced young
people from discrimination from
Prejudice and disadvantage but also I
think we need to do much more than that
because I think we need to be truly
aspirational for for our care
experienced young people as we are for
our own children and to seek the path
that will help them to reach their full
potential and also to lead the way
really with
um businesses in Trafford with our
partners with health education and
housing providers
so that they can do the same thing too
and I am certain that will get
cross-party support for this motion and
I do believe that that will be an
important step and but I do think and
this isn't intended really as an overly
political point but I do think to be
truly ambitious for our young people
I think this needs to be adopted
nationally by central government and it
needs significant investment into to
Children's Services really so that we
can remove those barriers that are faced
by our care experienced young people and
they urge everybody to support the
motion thank you mayor thank you
councilor Hines the motion has been
moved and seconded do any members wish
to speak on it right
the ones I spot first
gems
one two three four five six Oxford
rights
foreign
Jones Morgan
Lester Proctor and Oxford in that order
Blackburn
right so we'll kick off with councilor
new thank you
thank you Matt
strongly support the motion put forward
by a council Proctor this evening and I
have very valid reasons for doing so for
almost 10 years I worked as a
residential social worker in trafford's
children's homes and I became a
corporate parent to countless young
people each was accommodated by Social
Services for different reasons and none
was their fault no matter how much we
try to create a home from home
Residential Care particularly in an
embedded home is a very unique
experience
the average age of the young people in
my care in this particular instance was
14 to 16. seven of the nine were male at
one point five were on tag meaning that
they were forbidden by court order from
leaving the building between 7 pm and 7
A.M the atmosphere was mostly tense and
emotional and particularly at night
it was the norm for sleeping staff to be
awake on The Landings until around 3 A.M
calming and reassuring upset angry
bewildered young people While others
were intent on getting into each other's
rooms for Mischief prank and pranks and
other reasons staff members regardless
of poor sleep started the morning shift
at 7am and would begin waking the same
young people for the day ahead for
breakfast to school for on-site
education social worker or family visits
and it was extremely challenging
despite their living conditions and all
of the stress and distraction this would
inevitably bring these young people were
expected to behave achieve and conform
alongside other pupils whose home lives
could not be more different many not all
would drop out or be excluded from
mainstream education some could not
function along alongside other young
people and then it was very rare for
consideration to be afforded to these
young people living in a local Authority
at home one very extreme and not
entirely unusual example I wish to share
is of a young boy who came into our home
traumatized having witnessed his death
mute sibling being sexually abused by
their older brother over many years the
discovery of this abuse resulted in the
young man being accommodated
he would line up his toy soldiers at his
bedroom door to protect him from bad
people night times were his worst times
he was afraid of the dark mild manner
during the day he would become
disruptive at night in his desperate
need for the comfort brought by the
attention of others one night
fueled by a particularly emotional
family visit this young man locked
himself in his bedroom barricaded the
door and attempted to remove his face
with a razor blade because he disliked
himself so much
throughout all of this and despite the
best attempts from staff all the young
people this boy's friends heard
everything the fear the trauma the pain
we protected them from the horrific
scenes inside his bedroom where
paramedics arrived and the young man was
turned a few days later scarred but
physically okay
all the young people in the home were
expected to go to school and function
normally of course staff risk assessed
informed schools we involved cams and
social workers were very aware but still
being care experienced and all that this
brings really wasn't taken into
consideration
the scardial man had been desperate to
fit in and on arrival at our home within
hours he'd gone out with a group of
others and was present when a violent
Street robbery was committed he did not
take part was that sentencing the George
was Keen to make an example of the old
man in care and he was sent to
rejuvenile detention center
Social Services residential staff and
all who knew him said that to send him
away would be catastrophic for him
Our advice was ignored within weeks The
Fragile young teenager had choked
himself to death at the Detention Center
in a strip cell with a blanket meant to
cover his body
the care experienced children and young
people have always needed our protection
care and deep understanding this motion
is vital thank you mayor
thank you councilor new I'm gonna have
to start restricting people and I've
changed the order a little bit in terms
of being fair to all parties so we're
going to take councilor minis of the
maximum of two minutes followed by
councilor Morgan with a cap a maximum of
two minutes thank you thank you Mr Mayor
that's very emotional counseling you
um sorry
at the heart this motion is the
prevention of descript as well the aim
to prevent discrimination
liberal Democrats exist to build and
sell a safeguard Affair free and open
society in which we seek to balance the
fundamental values of Liberty equality
and community and in which no one shall
be enslaved by poverty ignorance or
Conformity that's a little bit from our
constitution but it's just a
the this is embedded in that really
uh this includes current care
experienced people the people who know
the Discrimination face are those with
the lived experience
we quite rightly have children in Care
at the top of our priority list for
allocation of school places and as a
health professional myself I know that a
young person being in care is a factor
in eligibility to health services that
otherwise wouldn't be provided
clearly more though needs to be done to
level the playing field and this motion
seeks to try to ensure fair treatment
for a group who otherwise face
discrimination
from listening to lived experience of
people in care tonight and having and
those that have left care it is clear
much more reflection is needed to ensure
fairness for all the liberal Democratic
group welcomed this motion and will be
supporting thank you thank you councilor
minis a few information just looking at
the clocks you've noticed that five
minutes different from each other the
one on my left hand side your right is
the one closest to being correct as you
probably know it's from your phones or
your computers we move on in my
estimation now to councilor Morgan to be
followed by councilor Leicester
uh thank you very much Mr Mayor um first
I'd like to say on behalf of
conservative group we will be supporting
this motion this evening
um I want to speak on this as this is
incredibly close to my heart
um probably have to declare an interest
um that my son is adopted and so by
definition he is a care experienced
child I'm not going to speak about
um some further but my experience on
getting
on going through to being approved to be
an adoptive parent and all the
experiences since certainly have taught
me so so much about this incredibly
important group in our society
um so as of March last year
there are just over a hundred thousand
children in care in the UK most aren't
toddlers less than one in five in
England
um 18 of five to nine and nearly 65 to
over ten and the rate of children going
into care is faster than the um growth
in the UK child population
again given the time we're not going to
go into stats because and also because
behind those stats are people every
person going into the care system will
have experience of how they went in
their experiences in the case and how
they leave it
um
and others have said about some of the
discrimination and prejudices group
faces both as children and as adults
um there's a bit of an antidote that um
it's highlighted to me in a BBC
documentary from a few years ago um
we're a care experience young adult
discussed his experiences as a child and
honestly your heart wants to break when
he said that as a child some of the
parents of his classmates were told told
them to leave him alone and not play
with him because he was a bad person
um this is a group that faces prejudice
and discrimination for the whole of
their lives as others particularly um
councilor Sherlock Proctor has said
so for those who ask why we need support
this is there a group who needs needs
this more
more of our support as a as a as a
counselor as a society as a country and
a group that we desperately need to
improve their life experiences thank you
very much Mr Mayor thank you councilor
Morgan councilor Leicester
thank you chair
um firstly I'd like to say thank you to
all the young people who came before and
spoke to us it really takes courage to
speak out like they did and I think they
were absolutely phenomenal uh at this
but really well and I think they also
brought things out that aren't
necessarily the things that you would
automatically think so that when they
were talking about some of the support
that they needed it wasn't necessarily
the first thing that you might that
might come to mind so they brought a
very different perspective and I mean
they were fantastic so we would support
the principles and agree highlighted in
this motion and agree that the
experience of young people currently in
care and Care leavers needs to be given
a clear clear consideration when making
any decisions and that they should be
considered as part of any any inequality
impact Assessments in decision making as
well and actually I was trying to
looking through the policy and probably
my only comment actually is is it I
agree with all of it or we agree with
all that is this it doesn't particularly
talk about traffic as an employer so um
so so I'm just thinking almost a
suggestion going forwards to actually
incorporating that be a bit more
explicit about that about traffic as an
employer in terms of what their
processes would be
um I think that's that's really the main
things I wanted to say so I think it's
an excellent motion all right thank you
councilor Leicester and with another
motion to come we're now going to go
down to one minute for each of the next
four speakers councilors Jones Proctor
Oxford and Blackburn in that order
councilor Jones thank you uh thank you
Matt um I wasn't going to speak but this
is very close to my heart and thank you
Kath
um Shirley for bringing us motion I'm
dealing with it in the council in such a
respectful way I've lived experience of
this not as the roles that you
um have
um foster parents Etc I was one of those
children
in the 1970s in Liverpool in care
so this is very important
I've learned to become determined to get
over the issues
have encounters over the years so it's
very important that we can break down
barriers and give respect to people like
myself
thank you thank you councilor Jones
[Applause]
and councilor Proctor
motion tonight we know from research and
I know our own awareness that care
leavers experience extreme difficulty
not just in their early years but
throughout their whole life
as I've heard this takes the form of
discrimination stigma and Prejudice
which often takes place in the data in
our day-to-day lives and makes it much
more harder than to achieve their true
potential
it also brings up barriers in their
long-term development and happiness
this is evidence in the way that care
experienced children are sometimes
discussed in schools workplaces in the
media and even on occasions regrettably
by professionals working in the care
sector
as a long-term former traffic Foster
carer with the other Council Proctor and
our kids has already as has already been
mentioned we looked after children who
came into care for a 13-year period
these came from many different
backgrounds with a variety of reasons
coming into care with many different
issues and problems
has also been mentioned our first
hospital in our 31 and 29 and we're
still very much involved in them and
have a witnessed the long-term effects
of them being in care has caused them to
no fault of their own
so in seeing firsthand the difficulties
then they face not only as children but
now as young adults and the kind of
thing they need to overcome which are
incredibly challenging and difficult
this situation is made worse for many by
the fact that there is a general
distereotypical public perception of
care experienced children or redeemingly
damaged
I
hope that we get four cross party
supports this motion tonight as we've
heard from the the children
previously
um
they definitely need that support and I
don't see why they can't can't be in
objections at all right thank you
Council thank you do we have to move on
thank you councilor Oxford
I just briefly
came to speak to us today when working
as a welfare benefits advisor I was only
too aware how care leavers can fall
between the cracks I met many care
leavers under the age of 18 who had to
fight to receive Universal Credit as
under 18s can only receive this benefit
in exceptional circumstances they are
required to provide evidence that they
were no longer under the care of Social
Services or receiving any parental
support or that they had limited
capability to work having to justify
their need for support with their claims
delayed
we have an enormous duty of care for
those with care experience status as I
say it takes a whole village to raise a
child and this motion goes some way to
offering this please support this motion
thank you thank you councilor Oxford
councilor black councilor Miss Blackburn
uh thank you Mr Mayor uh looked after
children children in care these are
labels there are young people
um children and young people in the
borough and they've suffered trauma and
it's our responsibility to make sure
that they're protected loved that
they've got good Role Models good
education and they're given life skills
so that they can can become not
necessarily mended because
people aren't always men it's like a
vars you drop a vars and you have a
crack or it breaks and you seal that
vasel but there's cracks are still there
so it's our it's our job our
responsibilities corporate parents to
ensure that we do the very very best for
our children or young people without
giving them that label and we've got to
do that for the future thank you thank
you councilor Miss Blackburn councilor
Shirley Proctor has a right of reply on
this
yeah to conclude I didn't expect I'd be
sacrine
thank you that's all I can say thank you
thank you right so I think debate has
finished I will now put the motion to
the vote all those in favor
all those against
are there any abstentions the motion is
carried unanimously we move on to motion
8e please can cancel the Harding move
the next motion regarding the Trafford
poverty truth commission thank you
councilor Harding thank you
firstly can I say a huge thank you to
all of the community and Civic
Commissioners who have been involved in
the work of the Trafford poverty truth
commission it cannot have been easy for
Community Commissioners to share deeply
personal and emotional experiences of
poverty
regardless of how often we talk in this
Council about living rooms cost of
living crisis and our response to it
food banks and crisis payments there is
still a huge stigma attached associated
with poverty
there are also many false stereotypes of
what a person or a family living in
poverty looks like
frankly as much as I am proud of
everything this Council has stepped up
to and done in relation to the cost of
living crisis I'm appalled that these
services are now seen as a normal part
of everyday life
if you haven't read the report I would
like to encourage all members to read
the final report and the recommendations
from the poverty truth Commission
18 pages in this report doesn't really
do justice to the emotional investment
and energy that has gone into it
I do believe that unbreakable
relationships and friendships have been
forged as a result of this Commission
and in their words
poverty does not define us but it is one
thing that we share
the four recommendations are laid out in
the motion and the report and at the
launch of the report last week I gave my
firm commitment that we would continue
to work towards the recommendations of
the commission
the recommendation that speaks the
loudest to me is nothing about me
without me I promise that all of you
involved in the poverty truth commission
did not share your stories for them to
remain in a glossy report this labor
Administration has made a firm
commitment as one of our priorities to
eradicate poverty we will pledge to
continue to work with you and find
solutions to the recommendations
proposed thank you mayor thank you
councilor Harding and I believe
councilor whitam is to second the motion
thank you Jeff
yeah I mean this this motion follows on
really nicely I think from the the
previous one because at the heart of it
is about you know listening to people
and engaging with people who often
struggle to have their voices heard and
that's about much more than boating
systems it's about engaging people in
participatory meaningful ways and the
poverty truth commission has very much
adhered to those those principles
I'm pleased to see the recommendations
coming out of the poverty truth
commission and that we're endorsing
upcepting them uh tonight councilor
Harding has and maybe others will come
up on the detail of those
recommendations and and the need for
Action to to address poverty across our
communities I just wanted to say a
little bit really about the process and
the journey
um that we've been on
we know for many people in our
communities poverty is a blight on their
on their lives and that's why as a labor
group we're moving towards real living
wage accreditation as well as we're
delivering multiple activities through
our poverty strategy
over the last 13 years the conservative
government has placed huge pressure on
councils like ours on on people on low
and middle incomes but also on public
service providers
through a failure to invest in people
and places more and more people have
found themselves struggling financially
and found that the services that they
rely on have been cut back or in some
instances completely completely
decimated
in spite or perhaps because of that
councils including ours have had to be
Innovative and think differently find
new ways of working and new solutions to
all problems
the poverty truth commission is an
example excellent example of that way of
working we as a council have not assumed
we've got all the answers
we've also enabled something to happen
we've engaged with something but we've
actually actively not taken the lead
we've been part of it but not sought to
lead it which I think has been really
important
The Poetry truth commission Journey
first started when councilor Hines and I
met with colleagues from Trafford
Housing Trust and representatives from
the voluntary and Community sector
um at St John's I think it was what
seems a very long time ago now and
rightly the property truth commission
was put on hold when we went into the
the pandemic but I can't thank Council
officers Trafford Housing Trust
colleagues and Stratford public hall
enough for really picking up the project
as we came out of the the pandemic there
was lots of competing priorities at that
time lots of Demands on both ourselves
and Trafford Housing Trust and
colleagues in the voluntary Community
sector but officers and colleagues in
partner organizations really did go with
the idea and run with it and thanks also
to councilor Patel and Sarah Salah for
engaging in the commission as a Civic
Commissioners that's been really
important that we've had Council
Representatives both officer and elected
member as part of the commission
as with the community response to the
pandemic which I was fortunate probably
not the right word but fortunate enough
to be involved with uh alongside
councilor Harding the poverty truth
commission required a commitment to
partnership working and recognition that
organizations and individuals are
stronger when they work together
whilst the main Drive is to support
people who are struggling financially
and to boost living standards sit with
central government there's much we can
do to support people locally
often what is needed is a more open and
accessible accessible approach to Public
Services where people are referred to
support that is responsive to their
needs recognizes and removes barriers
people may have in accessing those
services and doesn't require them to
repeat their story multiple times and
provide information to multiple
different agencies again I think that
challenges some of the things we've been
talking about in the previous motion
could I ask you counselor to try and
draw to a closer we can have some some
words from one or two other members
before we have to close that is why the
recommendations coming out of the
commission around access to services are
so important and why we and other
service providers in the borough should
commit to continuing to be informed by
the commission at the work of the
commission into the future and on a
personal note it's my last council
meeting so I'm really pleased that we've
got to this point that we've completed
the poverty truth commission journey and
it's my pleasure to second the motion
thank you councilor whitam
um so the motion has been moved and
seconded do any members wish to speak on
this motion Council Patel
others Holden
Alice if I get the names right this time
your own blackburns
I've got counselors Patel Holden Ennis
Jerome and Blackburn
and assuming there's going to be no one
else puts their hand up late
I could say that each of you have a
minute so councilor Patel thank you just
some brief Reflections on the poverty
truth commission I was privileged to be
one of the Civic Commissioners and hand
on heart I felt it was the one of the
most meaningful projects I've ever been
involved in I would like as councilor
Harding did just to take an opportunity
to thank everyone involved particularly
the community Commissioners who were
made up from residents from across the
brother who took the very brave decision
to get involved and share their personal
stories and challenge Civic
Commissioners on assumptions and
expectations of people living in poverty
we've had mention tonight a lot of the
discussion about how we connect with
people and I can honestly say that this
was achieved within the poverty truth
commission those who wouldn't usually be
heard were given a genuine voice and I
know for all involved it was a really
positive experience that that we won't
forget and a key part of this process is
the meaningful change that will come
from it so wholeheartedly support the
recommendations that the poverty truth
commission came to and just finally I
would like to thank councilor Graham
Whitton for initiating and driving this
in its early stages thank you thank you
very much councilor Patel councilor
Holden
thank you Mr Mayor
we live in a world of empty slogans
this isn't one of them
I've been presented with a slogan that I
can live by I want to live by nothing to
us without us
that can come on a T-shirt and if you
can make it 3XL buy three
thank you councilor Holden councilor
Ennis
thank you Mr Matt liberal Democrats
fully supporting this motion I just
wanted to take the opportunity to pay
tribute to Tina and Paul Huxley in my
ward and congratulate GeForce Cafe for
the amazing work they've done on the
community grocery they've set up in
broomwood it's 4 000 pounds worth of
groceries sold for just a few hundred
pounds and I actually think the council
has a role to play without supporting
this work I think in terms of helping
GeForce signpost people to other
services that seems to be a gap that I
think the council could step into at the
moment
as Council Hardy knows Tina was
recognized with an international women's
day award and I also wanted to pay
tribute to that process
as a community champion and that's
exactly what she is Mr Mayor liberal
Democrats support this motion thank you
councilor Ennis councilor Jerome
thanks chair
um we also welcome this motion and
recognize the good work done by the
Trafford poverty truth commission
um whoops there's my uh
just been singing and understanding from
those that work in this area and from
people who experience poverty at first
hand is vital this can inform policy
inform understanding and create better
access to resources for those that most
need it this couldn't be more important
after the global pandemic and the
current cost of living crisis we know
this work is aimed at tackling poverty
creating inclusivity and inequality it
also seeks to help tackle mental health
and ice and isolation a massively
important area for an aging Trafford of
course we will be supporting this motion
however both Manchester and Salford who
preceded trafford's work note that
tackling poverty needs Myriad Solutions
the green party has been for some time
calling for a universal basic income the
green party will take an additional
approach based on the principle of real
Social Security the policies will
improve everyone's lives and we have
asked Trafford labor whether they
support the universal basic income and
counselor Harding has promised a couple
of times that she would tell us the
executive's position on that so it would
be good to hear that one day but we we
welcome this motion and the word thank
you thank you thank you chair so
councilor Miss Blackburn
uh thank you Mr Mayor
um
conservative group will be supporting
this motion thank you councilor Harding
and councilor Whitson no decent person
wants poverty to continue so let's all
do something about it thank you all
right thank you councilor Miss Blackburn
um councilor Harding has a right to
reply at this point to conclude the
debate
just to say thank you very much for your
support and thank you to everybody
involved never ever think that you are
exempt from poverty never ever think
that this won't happen to you that is
why we have much to do please read the
report and read the stories from our
community Commissioners thank you Matt
thank you councilor Harding I'll now put
the motion to the vote all those in
favor
all those against are there any
abstentions the motion is carried
unanimously it's good to end this
meeting on a double consensual
tone and this is in fact the end of the
meeting this particular part of the
meeting however that's the end of the
main meeting and it's now proposed to
hold an informal meeting of the council
to consider issuing invitations to
members of the council to be the mayor
and deputy mayor of the borough for 2023